there was some really interesting uh
video from
biden's press conference a couple days
ago i think it was on thursday or friday
if i'm not mistaken been very busy over
here
where a news max reporter i think it's
james rosen uh i believe it was james
rosen yeah we'll see in just a sec he
actually
commented on biden's cognitive decline
yes
thank you very much for this honor james
rosen with newsmax i'd like to um i'd
like to raise a delicate
subject but with utmost respect for your
life accomplishments and the high office
you hold
a
poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49 percent of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
strongly affirmed that statement
well i'll let you all make the judgments
are correct well so the question i have
for you sir if you'd let me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor such profound
concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
that was it i have no idea and then he
mumbled something a little bit earlier
before that now look i don't want to
make
light of cognitive decline i don't want
to make light of dementia or alzheimer's
or any of that stuff i have told you
guys many times i spent a lot of time
with my grandma elaine who i absolutely
adored and loved and laughed with more
than anyone else on this earth
when she developed dementia in her last
couple years and a lot of repetition and
frustration
and then some good times happen too
because you forget some some of the pain
in life and she sort of became who she
was supposed to be at the end
but i'm not diminishing any of the
horror related to any of that because it
will affect everyone one way or another
whether it affects you personally or
someone in your family or friends or
anything that being said joe biden is
purportedly the president of the united
states he's supposed to be in charge
he's supposed to be the guy with the
finger on the button he's supposed to be
the guy that is the pilot of the plane
the captain of the ship
50
basically half of the people in the
country do not believe he's right
so whether
he has dementia or just old person
syndrome or something else or it's just
that he's old and there's a lot of
freaking pressure on him and suddenly
his stutter is coming back that's what
they're sort of telling us like whatever
it is if half the people think that
there is something truly wrong with you
and we all know about the mumbling the
confusion and forgetting people's names
and everything else it's like whatever
the truth is whatever specifically the
truth is
related to a diagnosis or whatever it's
like that's actually secondary to
there's a legitimacy problem even with
democrats but note that was a newsmax
reporter it's not talked about on nbc
it's not talked about
on
you know cnn or read about in the new
york times watching or anything but it
will be
right and when it will be then they'll
all go oh we all knew we all knew and
then you're going to watch people in the
administration and they're going to go
well i wanted to tell everybody i was
the guy going something's not right here
and it seems odd to me that they have to
drug him before he goes on stage or
whatever it is that they do to him or
that he had to keep going to bed at 2
p.m and we put a lid on everything at 3
p.m and blah blah blah blah so they the
rats on the ship they're going to bolt
when they realize that the ship is
sinking right they're going to get on
the life rafts um but this is a problem
this is a problem that we just don't do
these things honestly in real time no
pun intended related to the mars segment
before it's like we can all see things
but the airlock on the system doesn't
let us all talk about it at the same
time and maybe that was all okay
for many many years but in the time of
the internet and social media
it doesn't kind of work too many of us
are realizing the truth and what do you
do with all that
to that point on nbc's meet the press
which is basically a democrat program
chuck todd is obviously a democrat okay
obviously
even on nbc
even chuck todd is having to slightly
address
some of this stuff that's how
bad it's gotten that's how much
bludgeoning there is in this situation
take a look new nbc news poll suggests
mr biden does need a reset because he's
lost his identity a bit he's no longer
seen as competent and effective
he's no longer seen as a good commander
in chief or perhaps most damaging as
easygoing and likable in fact just five
percent of adults say mr biden has
performed better than expected as
president one of the many lowest
firsts and fewests in our poll
and as we kick off our meet the midterms
coverage heading into november the nbc
news political unit developed what we're
calling a midterm meter it's based on
previous election cycles it's basically
three poll numbers you need to know best
i'm going to start with the perhaps the
most important number to understand
uh the direction of the midterms it's
job approval here the president's job
approval rating is sitting at 43
if you look at history history shows
that kind of presidential approval
rating leads to a shellacking for the
party in power how about the mood of the
nation well let me show you this right
now our wrong track nation's on the
wrong track number sitting at 72 percent
second poll in a row where we've been
over 70 it's only the third time in our
polls history over 30 years where we've
had two tracks
that uh where that off that again would
put you in shellacking territory for the
party in power okay so when chuck todd
at msmb they're at nbc it's all the same
[ __ ] but at nbc
is
ringing the alarm right when he's
sounding the bell when he's screaming
about all this stuff
now look we know
that in the midterm elections usually
the incumbent president's party gets
whacked right it's just what happens it
happened to obama it happened to clinton
before that it happened to bush it
happened to trump like the people are
just like oh this guy isn't so great or
not as great as we thought he was going
to be so like the other guys come in and
it's always easier to be more robust in
your attacks and everything else when
you're not the party that's in charge in
essence so things are obviously tracking
really well for the republicans and in
this case it's not just because biden's
a disaster it's because republican
states are being run better at the
moment there's something called policing
you know there's something called
election integrity uh there's something
called you know allowing people to go to
work and not lock everybody down and not
forcing them to be injected like there's
a lot of stuff happening right now but
what chuck todd is doing there is he's
warning biden basically because he
realizes how bad it is so that that's
good now again chuck is he's a democrat
obviously he's pretending right he's
pretending to be this impartial thing
but what he really wants to happen which
is why he's doing the segment is biden
to fix this thing not because he's he's
just an american who would want things
to be better but he doesn't want his
guys to lose power but i don't even want
to make this about chuck todd's too
specifically the point is
that to link this entire show together
if i had a thread through this entire
show
we all see something ain't right we all
see something right sometimes we don't
all see it at the exact same time
but now i think it's our job
to
help the people who aren't seeing it as
clearly as us get to that conclusion